one key senator says when it comes to
immigration reform it's the president's
way or no way at all this comes as the
White House ups the pressure on Senate
Democrats during what is supposed to be
a rare open debate on this subject chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
tells us where we are right now that
expires beginning March the fifth so we
know we have a deadline the president
has offered a generous proposal
Republicans favored a plan offered by
these six GOP senators which is the
legislative version of president Trump's
blueprint which resolves daca
strengthens border security eliminates
the Visa Lottery and ends extended
family chain migration there is no
reason why reasonable people in Congress
can't get together and get behind this
yet the day after voting 97 to one to
start debate in the Senate the top
leaders could not agree on how to begin
let's get this debate started on the
right foot so I object to the leaders
request that led some Republicans to
conclude Democrats don't want a solution
they'd prefer a 20-18 campaign issue
today the majority leader said he wants
to get something done this week there's
no reason no reason not to come together
and get a solution this week this has
been going on and ylim they shut down
the government over this the Democratic
whip blamed the White House on September
5th of last year it was a president who
ended up ending the daca program
effective March 5th of this year and
challenging Congress to respond the
Senate Democratic leader said
cooperation will be necessary I think
the sooner the better
and if we can come up with a bipartisan
compromise that looks like it's right in
the ballpark of 60 let it rip let's go
but a key conservative says the
president's proposal is a best and final
offer it's the president's framework
bill or nothing that they do want to in
fact
uphold the promises that they made the
Democrats made to protect these young
illegal immigrants some leading
Republicans say it's either the
president's offer or a more conservative
option from House Judiciary Chairman Bob
Goodlatte it is clear that GOP believes
votes on issues like sanctuary cities
and other components are potentially
damaging to red state Democrats up this
year right my commander will live on the
hill Mike thanks